on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight on PE Morgan on sensor back with
a bang and two big exclusives sque Khan
says his climate change cameras will
clear the air could they cost his party
but hang on let's start again sh because
that's got nothing to do with Tonight
Show uh that's got nothing to do with it
so I'll tell you what we're going to do
we're going to actually show you what
life television's like we're going to
put the correct intro in there and start
again should we start again
everyone I'll tell you what let's just
go to my monologue shall
[Music]
we live from the news building in London
this is Pier Morgan
uncensored well it's certainly
uncensored now cuz I was about to say
something but was would be really
uncensored but you know what it's my
first day back at the studio after a
week in covid hell so I'll forgive the
misant that just created that little
drama for us and we'll move on I'll kill
them after the show uh well good evening
from London welcome to Pi Morgan
uncensored uh tonight on the show rishy
sunak is grilled at the co inquiry as
the Rwanda plan backlash raises fresh
questions about his leadership as even
talk of a Boris Johnson and Nigel farage
dream ticket which strikes me as the
opposite of a dream Abdul wahed is the
leader of an islamist movement which
glorified the Hamas attacks chanted for
Jihad on the Streets of London he's also
in his day job in NHS GP and he'll join
me live in the
studio well I'm a passionate defender of
free speech there's a massive clue in
the name of this show uncensored and I
believe in it I believe that all honesty
held opinions however offensive they are
belong in the open where they can be
challenged debated and exposed but there
are limits on Free Speech there are laws
and there is a line I've always said
that Alex Jones is a perfect example of
where that line got crossed he's a
conspiracy theorist and shock jock in
America who made hundreds of millions of
dollars by pedaling outrageous lies at
the Sandy Hook school massacre shooting
was a hoax for the uninitiated this is
him shouting at me a week after that
Massacre on CNN the tyrants did it
Hitler took the guns Stalin took the
guns ma took the guns Fel Castro took
the guns Hugo Chavez took the guns and
I'm here to tell you 1776 will commence
again if you try to take our Firearms
doesn't matter how many limings you get
out there on the street begging for them
to have their guns taken we will not
relinquish them do you understand you
kind of won that debate actually because
the only response in America to the
Sandy hood massacre was to do nothing in
fact they continue to sell a lot more
guns a million new guns get sold in
America America every month and they're
already over 400 million in circulations
if you're wondering if you're curious
why there are so many more mass
shootings in America than they used to
be that's why and if you're wondering
what's going to happen in the next few
years as a million new guns ENT
circulation and nothing gets done to
stop mass shootings my guess is there'll
be a lot more mass shootings I've
covered a lot of them especially when I
was at CNN in America very few of them
uh in fact none of them actually were
were Soul crushing a Sandy Hook 20
children aged between six and seven were
murdered by a mass killer with a
semi-automatic AR-15 rifle Alex Jones's
reaction to this absolute appalling
atrocity was to tell his followers on
his infow War show it was all a
government hoax set up by the Obama
Administration a deep State plot to
justify new gun laws that would take
away their guns he said The Grieving
families were all crisis actors
Sandy Hook it's got inside job written
all over it Sandy Hook is a synthetic
completely fake with actors in my view
manufactured I couldn't believe it at
first people just instinctively know
that there's a lot of fraud going on uh
but it took me about a year with Sandy
Hook to come to grips with the fact that
the whole thing was
fake was a direct result of his lies
those grieving families were harassed
and threatened with death by his
followers uh Erica lafy daughter of the
murder principal Dawn Haw sprung got
death and rape threats from people who
said her mother was fictional Robbie
Parker who lost his daughter Emily was
chased down the street by Jan supporter
asking how much he'd earned by lying
about the death of his daughter Mark Bon
father of seven-year-old victim Daniel
Bon says that one of Jones's followers
urinated on his dead son's grave some of
these families have successfully sued
him now for defamation which is
explicitly not protected by America's
First Amendment Jones was ordered to pay
record damages more than a billion doar
in total he's yet of course to pay a
penny he actually declared himself
bankrupt to avoid doing so nevertheless
Elon Musk has inexplicably decided it's
time to restore Alex Jones to X formerly
Twitter I'm a big supporter generally of
Elon Musk I think the work he's doing to
eradicate bias and Protect free speech
in the place where so many debates now
originate is an important very important
one but this was a profoundly
disappointing and wrong decision I'd
like to remind Elon what he said about
reinstating Alex Jones when he first
took over he said this he said he
wouldn't restore him and said my
firstborn child died in my arms I felt
his last heartbeat I have no mercy for
anyone who would use the deaths of
children for gain politics or fame well
that is precisely what Alex Jones did he
literally used children for gain Fame
and politics so what's changed in a year
Elon well there's now a big movement to
rehabilitate Alex Jones online many
argue he's right more often than he's
wrong when all the evidence points to
the complete opposite and in the case of
Sandy Hook it wasn't just one little
mistake that he owned up to Andrew Tate
tweeted Alex Jones is an effing hero
really he's not my kind of hero he's the
opposite of a hero this is a man who
repeatedly and deliberately lied about
the mass shooting of children at school
to enrich himself he called it all as
phony as a $3 bill and yet that's what
he is yes he's now apologize but he did
that under legal Jess because his
business was about to go to the wall
this wasn't something he blurted out
once and instantly regretted he did this
for years and every time he lied about
Sandy Hook he made more money
night after night day after day week
after week month after month year after
year and he knew what was going on to
these families as a result of his
harassment on air to see him back on X
selling his book his merchandise his
website his infow Wars frankly makes me
want a
puke every opinion should be heard but
inciting harassment and violence to
profit from unspe speakable grief to
pour into the wounds of those families
yet more misery and pain that's not free
speech it's deliberate hate speech and
it's
disgusting well kicking off the week uh
I'm joined by my pack talk to
contributor Esther kru associate editor
of the mirac Kevin McGuire political
journalist Ava Santina just we're going
to get into British politics but just
your your reaction Kevin first of all to
that we're going to be debating it later
on the show but Elon Musk bringing back
Alex Jones who has still not paid a dime
of that $1.2 billion doar of damage he
one of the record defamation settlements
in American history but given the people
that he
defamed what do we think of this
decision yeah where's musk's Humanity
where's his his had it a year ago it's
gone in fact he compared it to the death
of his own child in his arm it's gone
I'm afraid he's thrashing around like
Twitter's Worth or X as he's renamed it
as worth less than half what he paid for
it he's desperate to get people on he
thinks you'll get controversy and
followers and somehow if he thinks he's
going to attract advertisers and make
money from that he's he's utterly wrong
look he deserves musk deserves to fail
now on on Twitter X I'm on it you're on
it everybody's on it on it here well
we're all on this platform thing if
you're going to be the champion of free
speech you're going to have unsavory
characters like Alex Jones if you've
backed yourself into a corner by saying
you're the person that has this platform
that's going to Champion Free Speech you
you effectively have to let him back on
I I I have I have no interest in
anything and I I do think my experience
of X has really gone off a Cliffs since
since you been buying it but this this
is a this is a matter of principle if
you're going to say that I'm the king of
free speech well this is what you have
to Theory takes off people who mock him
apparently accounts about him so so he
defends himself also the point about
free speech in America there are many
things the first amendment does not
protect when it comes to free speech
incitement to any violence defamation as
we've discussed that what he was saying
that he was found guilty of is not
covered by Free Speech fraud obscenity
child pornography fighting words and
threats there are many things you can't
say and be covered by even America's
First Amendment widely acknowledged to
be one of the broadest supporters of
free speech in the world yeah so you
know this idea that somehow Alex Jones
is a free speech Warrior it's just
nonsense yeah well they'll probably deem
that the First Amendment isn't adequate
anymore but look you know this is also
something we're importing over here I
think we're seeing free speech and the
the the apparent merits of free speech
is diluting our politics over here it's
something that a lot of the national
conservatives are getting into and it's
really worrying okay let's turn to UK
politics let's turn Uh Kevin to the co
inquiry Richie Sun I mean this is a guy
right on the ropes at the moment I
watched about two hours of the inquiry
today and I have to say it's sort of
confirm my view if richy sunak had been
the leader before that he became leader
he might have said a much better chance
he came over to me as pretty diligent
intelligent calm you know talked his way
through the various issues accepted you
know things had gone wrong accepted
things had gone right whatever he was a
kind of you know an impressive I felt an
impressive witness yeah Am I Wrong to
think that but for for a man who says
he's a master of detail it must have
been more than 20 times he couldn't
recollect he couldn't recall he couldn't
grasp it he didn't know it was as if he
hadn't been in
in the room so I I thought look he
decided you you make the apology try not
to be tety uh not attack those who
disagreed with I thought that was all
clever strategy but I felt the number of
times his memory failed him and the
number of messages he'd lost when
supposedly transferred stuff there stuff
on the WhatsApp messages the number of
them now who are claiming well they all
disappear when I changed my vot I've
changed this watch what he said the the
Prime
Minister you don't now have access to
any of the whatsapps that you did send
during the time of the crisis do you no
that I don't I've changed my phone
multiple times over the past few years
and as that has happened the messages
have not come across as you said I'm not
a prolific user of WhatsApp in the first
instance primarily communication with my
private office and obviously anything
that was of significance through those
conversations or exchanges would have
been recorded officially by my civil
servants as one would expect now what I
don't understand Boris Johnson said the
same thing when I've changed my phone
the WhatsApp messages just come over
automatically your account I think the
thing is and also by the way if you're
the if you're the chancellor or the
prime minister of this country why
aren't your all your messages
automatically preserved for the country
that is paying your salary I think the
bigger question is that why are
politicians using WhatsApp I think it's
deeply unprofessional but it should they
can use it but it should all be saved
well but the thing is they they are
saved in America you can't circum naate
they're all public record the thing is
if the police
conducting a criminal investigation they
will have access to your whatsapps even
if you physically deleted them off your
phone right so they're not lost if they
if it if it warranted a police
investigation they would be able to
retrieve those WhatsApp but I do think
Richi sunak handled himself very well I
think during the inquiry there was a
question about whether he mocked um
rashford's uh sort of plan to to to give
uh kids free School meals that's
completely irrelevant to the inquiry I
mean most of us are watching this
thinking I really hope there's a point
to this there are four more modules of
this inquiry and to ask a politician at
the time the problem his opinion of
initiative was is irrelevant it's all
going to take too long right time this
is finished we're all half dead anyway
right ironically um there probably be
another pandemic by this all takes far
too long in this country in Sweden
they've done and dust it already they
finished but I also think the limits of
the inquiry have really been tested by
these whatsapps I think it's you know
fun and trivial to look at and just go
well how on Earth do you delete them but
quite seriously if you really cared and
you wanted to retrieve those messages
you would have a list made of everyone
that they ever message and you would
retrieve those messages from the re that
is possible to do you would use the res
it's hard to imagine a more serious
collection of messages than the people
running the government at the start of a
pandemic I mean this is serious
historical record we're talking yeah
Hillary Clinton's use of private em in
2016 huge scand was a huge contribution
the of her losing against Donald Trump
in fact there was no evidence she
misused it but she but she used it when
she shouldn't and of course here you
have Boris Johnson you have the
chancellor the
how can they get away with it as well
this happened with so rman she was
sacked because she was using a private
email to communicates why on Earth is
that any different when richy soon when
I don't I don't think I think in in the
grand scheme of things these WhatsApp
messages Frank Frankly are IR relevant I
want to know about the PPE contracts I
actually want to know where money was no
but the thing no but there's a record of
actual the the the contract I think is
right a lot of his stuff is probably
there but it's disappeared right because
they don't want to be held accountable
for when you smell a rat we're talking
of talking smelling rats Nigel farage
came third in I'm a celebrity get me out
of here um I have absolutely no truck
with a little snake because of what he
did to me over Donald Trump right which
just to remind viewers when I launched
this show having three months earlier
texted faroh my personal congratulations
when he got an interview with Donald
Trump he then tried to sabotage mine in
the most despicable snake likee manner
so I found his true colors then he's a
snake right and it was brilliant last
night to see him not only losing again a
public vote he's lost this is the
seventh six elections he's lost seven
this is seven now and he came third and
the winner was a bloke I've never heard
of he used to be in a reality show
called maen Chelsea years ago apparently
my son knows him on the nightclub
circuit in I want to challenge your son
by the way I don't think he's quite as
nice as your son really really he is
well Spencer assures me he's a good lad
I don't know I don't know I haven't met
him but I mean just the fact I've never
heard of him and somehow this is the
Glorious Triumph for farage what Triumph
are we talking about farage lost to a
reality TV star and ended up covered in
snakes appropriately why does that make
him more electable am I missing
something yeah but he's now got one and
a half million pounds so he can reopen
his bank account a very he's got enough
cash finishing third is where Matt
Hancock the health secretary finished
he's just the new a fellow I think I
think we're experting about of
collective Amnesia here to suggest that
Boris Johnson and niga farage are the
dream ticket has everyone forgotten the
last four years well I don't know also
is quite interesting because if he is
going to potentially run for office
again I mean he is still in a political
parties's in the Reform Party is this
not a question for the Electoral
Commission because this there's not been
free publicity for him for the past
couple of weeks he's been able to parade
himself and La his reputation and look
you know of course you got on well there
he is a very amiable person he's one of
the most wellknown people in the country
he doesn't need this free PR the bigger
problem it seems to me for Richie sunak
is this business about Rwanda which I
think is a policy and has been from the
very start and I think it's not going to
work and even if it does work it'll be
tiny and the cost it's cost for taxpayer
to generate a few people getting on a
plane for the Optics means seems to me
completely obscene oh it's a zombie
policy it's finished what 290 million
pound what will happen I mean is it
likely that enough Tory Rebels are going
to actually try and bring him down I've
often seen them bottle it uh at the end
so maybe tomorrow they don't bring him
down then but then have a go in January
February he can't escape this now if
this policy is is UN as unworkable as it
seems I think the Tor should let it fail
on its own Merit instead of outing Rishi
sunak as leader because honestly the you
know what I would do if was is facing is
I would just announce tomorrow and the
run after Christmas it's done we're
pulling out sorry we've had a good go at
this the only way to actually make it
properly work is probably as Robert
gener rightly identified is to break
international law I'm not prepared as
British prime minister for us to do that
nor as r
right the authoritarian leader of
repressive Randa W let's end with a bit
of fun with Richie this is artificial
intelligence having a bit of fun with me
and him in a clip that's gone viral on
Tik Tok shortly I'll be having a word
with the Prime Minister rishy sunak
after rishy had decided to block the
greedy BBC from implementing their
largest increase on their license fee in
40 years he will now be telling us why
he decided to take this action so rishy
why have you decided to block this huge
increase on the television license fee
Well appear to be frank I'm sick of them
taking the they're literally trying to
make the likes of the British public pay
the wages of Gary liner and Zoe ball I
mean come on who the watches the Telly
anymore
anyway he's won my vote yep yeah here
final word on it's pretty scary none of
that is real I mean that's quite scary
look you know if it's if it's labeled as
comedy political satire then that's fine
but when it's passed off is genuine
quick word about linut who's back in the
headlines again for expressing an
opinion I don't care what I me Gary's a
made of mind I don't care what he says
why why do we care so much about his
views because it's a lot easier to put
on the front page that you're upset with
Gary ler rather than you're upset with
the Prime Minister who you are in bed
with you know it's a lot EAS can you put
I think it's because the BBC pretends to
be impartial listen at the end of the
day I actually wonder why Gary L Contin
to work for the BBC if he feels this
strongly and he knows I think he likes
talking about
football to express himself but I'm surp
I wonder why he chooses to work for look
I'm I'm quite pleased he's not
complaining about foreign players coming
over here and taking our corners but you
know what it is it's papers like the The
Daily Mail on the right always
denouncing cancel culture but the moment
somebody says they don't something they
don't like they want to cancel it would
be quite interesting to see what they
were doing if ly suddenly did a complete
U-turn and started saying I'm fully in
favor of the I mean Almost Do It For Fun
right you started tweeting everything
that the conservative right agreed with
of course none of them would be
furious I don't think that's it I think
it's because the BBC license view is
going up we have to pay for this they
they shouldn't attack his right to say
as you rightly said in in the monologue
free speech that includes hearing what
you don't like and you don't agree with
it does but you know what Free Speech
does have limits and a society that even
a free Democratic Society that doesn't
impose limits on free speach is not
actually a thriving democracy it becomes
something else uh thank you Pat good to
see you all on Su next I'm join from
exclusive interview with the Suburban
NHS Doctor Who's been revealed to be the
leader of an extreme islamist group is a
GP calling for Gad something we should
tolerate that's
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about sport today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million milon pounds
so far result nil absolutely nil are we
only going to be trusting sources like
meta and Google where is our unbiased
news going to come from Kell in winter
is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan you have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan's about
the weirdest plank that we've had in
three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous M
he should be easy enough to catch this
guy shouldn't he I mean he's got house
full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not do an
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question
are you prepared to call h a terror
group is it possible to have a rational
I've asked you two questions should Hass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that
[Music]
welcome back to uncens my next guest has
been a GP with the NHS for 25 years
working as a mentor for recently
qualified doctors at his surgery in
Harrow Northwest London Dr wahed azif
Shader has another less wholesome
identity as leader of an is Islam
Islamic extremist Group which was
recently caught on camera calling for
Jihad at an anti-israel
demonstration what is the solution to
liberate people in the concentration
camp from palestin what is the
solution Shader also known as Abdul
wahed joins me now welcome T thank you
for coming in today um you've come from
your work as a NHS GP yeah um let me
first just ask you your reaction to the
clip we just played these are members of
your organization and they're a loud
chance of of jihad on the Streets of
London do you think that's
acceptable um that demonstration was a
very carefully planned demonstration
where the placards the banners the
speeches from the platform were calling
for a military intervention of official
armies of Muslim countries to rescue the
people of Gaza with a situation of a
civilian population of 2 million who are
being massacred and slaughtered anywhere
else in the world you would find it a
completely straightforward thing for
people calling for military intervention
but they weren't calling they weren't
chanting we want military intervention
they were chanting Jihad so so my
question for you is simply do you
support the chanting of jihad the
chanting of jihad by somebody that
unscripted well quite a few people there
actually actually no was about two
people so you would you would condemn
that of course I wouldn't condemn that
you wouldn't no because Jihad in that
context is as they understood it and
they were chanting is for the official
armies of Muslim countries to enter and
intervene we in a situation now appears
where
1% of the population of Gaza has been
killed in the space of 2 months 1% of
the children of Gaza have been killed
anywhere else in the world you yourself
called for military intervention in
Ukraine by NATO with probably less legal
and moral cause than there is in Gaza
when we stand oh absolutely because you
think the When Vladimir Putin illegally
invaded Ukraine the moral right of
ukrainians to respond is somehow
equivalent to the moral right of people
in Palestine after October the 7th to do
the same is that what you're saying I'm
saying that the people of Ukraine have
actually one of the most powerful armies
in the region it doesn't change the fact
they were illegally invaded do it the
people of Gaza have nobody helping them
well they they have
have nobody helping hang on hang on they
have a terrorist organization called
aass have nobody helping they got 30,000
terrorists who committed on October the
7th terrorism they have lined up against
them the murderous is Defense Force they
have lined up against them the United
States who this week today in the
Washington Post it was said that the
white phosphorus that's being used by
the IDF is supplied by them they have
lined up against them the Britain and
the EU they have lined up against them
the Arab rulers in the region who carry
on their trade cooperations listen as
I've made clear doctor I I think a lot
of the response from Israel particularly
right now I would deem to be testing
everyone's sense of what is
proportionate right there's no question
I do not subscribe to the view it's
genocide that is the understatement of
the Cent possibly but I think they have
I think they have a right to defend
themselves against a terror group who
have gone on record in the last two
weeks as saying they want to do what
happened again again understand it's
it's horrific it's horrific it's beyond
it's beyond horrific because literally
what we are watching what we are
watching on our phones on our laptops on
our TVs is is an extension of what's
been happening since 194 let me play you
your reaction all right I understand let
me play you after October the 7th a few
days later you took part in a talk on
YouTube and you said
this Brave mujah they gave the enemy a
punch on the nose all right and and it's
a very welcome punch on the
nose how can you categorize a terror
attack in which
1,200 mostly innocent civilian people
were brutally attacked raped tortured
beheaded and murdered how can you a
British NHS doctor or NHS doctor in
Britain how can you say that's a welcome
punch on my
nose will you let me answer fully yes I
will be frank I'll be as concise as I
can be but if you give me the courtesy
of letting me answer fully
okay I will defend the right of the
Palestinians to to resist an occupation
when you look at that that's not
resistance that's terrorism when you
look at what happened and the 7th of
October as if that is the day that
everything started I didn't say that you
didn't say that but when people look at
that do you think what happened that day
was a terrorist attack when people look
do do you the word terrorism has become
so uh uh politicized actually not really
the word the word teror deeply
sympathetic to the pride of Palestinian
civilian which I am by the way and I've
expressed many times what you can't do
is be weasly mou about what happened on
October 7 I asked you to was a gr you
finish but you're equivocating about it
being a terror I'm not equivocating and
I will explain why okay the the the word
terrorism by the way in India last last
month we don't talk about India talk
about the word terrorism in India people
who supported the Australian cricket
team have been arrested under terrorist
offenses in the West Bank people who are
revealing have been told if you reveal
what happened in the prisons you will be
arrested on terrorist do you think what
happened October the 7th was a terrorist
it's it's a resist it's a resistance not
a terror attack but appears if if and
it's NHS GP if I'm asking you to let me
finish if right our our Islamic standard
in conflict in Warfare our Prophet peace
be upon him sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he said you can't kill children you
can't kill women you can't kill the
elderly you can't mutilate all that if
anybody did that if what do you mean if
I say if because they literally
broadcast it on their own streaming
platforms and well I'll tell you what a
lot of us saw broadcast it merrily to
the world here's here's us doing these
terrible things what do you mean if what
many of us saw on that day were videos
coming out showing people saying we will
not harm women we will not har children
do me a no no that's what doctor I'm
saying that I'm saying that resistance
is a right in Islam it's a right in
international law it's even a right that
Churchill said in his history of the
english- speaking peoples that is he
actually he actually wrote in that book
it is a primary right of men to kill and
die for the land they live in you
literally just read me a description of
what people who follow Islam are not
supposed to do and Hamas did all of
those things but your response is to say
well hang on I've seen videos of them
saying we don't want to do that stuff no
I yes I find that pretty offensive
doctor I find we all know they did it
because I find they boasted to the world
with their own videos what they were
doing find I find it amazing that
respected journalists like yourself have
seem to have suspended their critical fa
I'm believing what Hamas wanted me to
see well you're believing what you saw
what Hamas themselves broadcast to the
world because they wanted to take great
Le in what they've done let me there's
no there's no ambiguity about it I asked
you to let me finish and I'm going to
you got to answer questions I will
answer the question let's agree on a
principle if atrocities were committed
right I will never condone them right I
will say that so do you condemn what
happened on October the 7th if
atrocities are committed you know who's
resp know they were who's responsible
for it then ah so you don't condemn it
okay who is responsible the Jews bought
it on themselves actually I would say
more more than that I would say the
powers that believe that Israel should
be a colony for themselves in the Middle
East they are the ones responsible you
know I'm really struggling I got to be
honest with you I'm really struggling
that a national a British National
Health Service doctor of 25 years a man
who's supposed to be seeing patients all
day every day and putting them right is
incapable of saying what happened when
it was literally broadcast to the World
by a terror group nor do you think
they're terrorists you think it's
resistance you seem to want to go way to
justify it you don't even believe what
they showed us with their with their own
technology and I'm I'm just curious do
you think any of this is compatible with
you being a doctor in the National
Health Service you don't have to be a
doctor do your patients know know that
believe you don't have to be a doctor
to care for the lives of two million
people in Gaza you don't have to be I'm
concerned about whether your patients
here in this country were Hamas are a
prescribed to terrorist organiz and I've
listening to interv do these do these
patients know your said to you do they
know your views I don't talk to my
patients about my views in a 10-minute
confrontation do I nobody does that it's
just a foolish question isn't it that's
a foolish question yeah nobody talks to
why do you use a different name for I
use my name well you don't you have two
names one the leader of the group Abdul
wahed is a name that family friends and
other people call me actually even some
people that's not the name you use at
work even some people at work and and
ABD and is my legal name which people
use in other forums that's not a very
unusual in May
2023 I no no I'm going to ask you
another question you did not give me the
courtesy you know why because your
answers were so outrageous you censor
that's your answer no no no no I don't
censor the person doing the censoring is
you you are who wants me to try and
understand and believe that what hamash
Sodus boasted about with their own
technology broadcasting into the world
was not what we saw you that's called
censorship well that is actually the
purest personification of censoring the
truth I've ever encountered when you
bring Mark reg onto the show yeah and
you you question him lightweight
questioning allbe it lightweight
questioning about the atrocities that
have happened you think I give I
actually ask you difficult question
actually you don't you don't ask
difficult questions yeah you completely
accept you listen sit there and listen
to the most ridiculous explanations
unlike you and your answers you mean
well you don't give me the chance to say
that no I've heard your no you didn't I
have I have you didn't you don't well
let okay let's do a little quick telling
you're telling the answer let's do a
little quick far recap do you think
Hamas are a terror group I believe it's
a resistance organization do you think
what they did in October the 7th was a
terror attack I believe that if
civilians got killed on that day it is
it is appalling it is apping you're a
doctor man is apping you're a doctor
inan also believe 1200 people got
massacred and 1% of the population I can
share your concerns about what's you no
you don't oh no I do no I do 16
years believe a doctor is saying the
word people got victims of atrocity if
if October the 7th how can you say that
so what you tell me this what is a
proportionate response to 16 years
living in a cage no what is a
proportionate resp not a terror attack
what is not a terror attack if they if
they just attacked IDF I've asked many
times what is proportion accept that so
you're saying just just to attack the
IDF would have been acceptable I
personally do not believe I'm answering
let me your question I'm going to say
this we might be able to agree might be
a to age I think the strategy at the
moment let me answer the question let me
answer the question let me answer the
question no if they had just military
targets acable my view of what they're
doing is I don't think it's going to
work I don't think the IDF is going to
eradicate Hamas and if that is the
mission statement and in the process
they killed tens of thousand
women and children if they do that I
think they will radicalize an entire new
generation and make it worse that's my
honest view of what I'm now witnessing
but let me come back to that's why
that's why when we talk about a military
intervention actually what we want
doctor what happened October 7th wasn't
a military intervention was a terror
attack what we want as a milit you don't
even think it happened do you what we
want is a military intervention from
Muslim armies to re rescue a beleaguered
people and replace anian people have to
be given the same human rights do me
respect they have to be given no no I
will interrupt you it's not your show
you don't just talk forever right what's
the point of asking I'm going to tell
you what I think about the Palestinian
plight which I've talked about many
times you've obviously missed it I think
they should be given the same human
rights as everybody else and
particularly the same rights of Israelis
I think it's been a 75 year conflict
with conflict a conflict where people
have been driven out of their homes
conflict 15,000 people in the wrong that
was wrong encroaching on the West Bank
more and more and more that was wrong so
have been all the wars launched against
Israel that's been wrong all of it is
wrong right the history shows this is a
conflict riddled with wrongs on both
sides of October no it didn't I never
said it did well you seem to you don't
even think it happened whole framing of
your debate you don't even think it
happened I do think it happened you did
it 1200 people were massacred I think
1200 people were killed were they
massacred yeah they were killed by
terrorists they were killed by people
who were resisting an occupation
and they're terrorists yeah
well that's your view it is my view by
the way it's a view of any any person
who is is not Israeli or Palestinian
right anyone can look disagree with that
I disagree with that one man have you
not heard the one man's terrorist is
another man's Freedom Fighter have you
never heard that have you never
heard let me just play I want to just
read you this in May 2023 lukar MIM
who's a prominent member of your
organization call for an end to the
secular order so that quotes the UK will
no longer be able to pump its liberal
filth its LGBT filth its feminist filth
Into the Heart of the Muslim world do
you agree with him I agree that the West
is pumping secular democracy into the
Muslim world and I LGBT fil I agree that
actually what we want to see in the
Muslim world is a system with an
accountable government right an elected
leader upholding Family Values right we
want to see an economic system where
wealth is circulated do you believe in
equal rights for gay people I believe I
believe that actually the the Islamic
standard of law should be the standard
of law in the country in the obviously
that's the standard I believe in and I
believe just to clarify what is your
view of homosexuality I believe
homosexuality is a sin don't sin wrong
so when gay people come to your your
practice do you treat them oh of course
why because I treat all my patients with
kindness and without you tell them you
think what they do is a sin what an
absurd thing to say why why wouldn't you
be why I say that why would I say that
because they don't come why don't you
try going back to your surgery tomorrow
come to me why don't you go to your
surgery tomorrow and say before we go
any further to your patients I want you
to know what I think I think that I
agree with a guy who said the this
country is full of LGBT filth feminist
fil I don't think Hamas are a terror
group I don't think what they did
October the 7th was a terror attack and
by the way do you want me how to treat
you do you want do you want you
understand what I don't understand any
of that professional Integrity is you
understand you think that's professional
Integrity no I think professional
Integrity is treating the people I treat
with respect and with kindness how do
fairness well they know I do do they oh
yeah do they oh yeah do they know you
think they're filth I didn't say that
they're filth you you agreed with what
he said I didn't agree with what he said
you said I agree no I agree I pay the T
back in your life I agree with the fact
that the Muslim World should have the
Islamic system yeah I didn't say I agree
with I don't use words you want full
Sharia law for this country for this
country I'm working for our group works
for Islam the restoration of Islam in
the Muslim world what about here we work
we work to uphold Islamic values in our
personal life and in the Muslim
Community do you want La here or no I
would love you know what you'd love it
no I tell you what that in this last two
months one of the strangest things has
been where people here have been looking
at the people in Gaza and they've been
going and looking and reading the Quran
and they've been looking at it and I'd
invite you and your audience to do that
I would do that and you like and they
are not convinced by these NE neocon
neocon and caricatures of Islam are they
actually I don't think people all I've
done is ask you straightforward question
you've revealed your beliefs in the
answers yeah you have I I you may not
even realize what you've done but you
have I believe in Islamic law and I
don't believe in the caricature that you
try and present of Islam would you like
Sharia law in this country I would love
to see I would love to see you want
Sharia law in this country I don't want
Sharia law in this country well that's
your wish but you would yeah but I no I
I would I believe it's the I believe
it's the best system but I'm not work
I'm not working would you like it in
this country I would I'm not working I
believe in Islamic you know or no you
know the Islamic civilization was the
only civilization to answer everything
else yes or no the Islamic civilization
was the only civilization that brought
peace to the Middle East for Muslims
Jews and Christians I would love to see
that system there wouldn't you like to
see a system who pays who pays your
salary wouldn't you like to see a system
Muslims Jews and Christians would live
Side by live under Sharia law it's not
talking about I'm talking about Middle
East no but you suggested you wanted it
to be under Sharia law you suggest do
you or not you you do you or not what's
what's funny what's funny is your
approach of question why just answer the
question because you know why it's funny
yes or no you either do or you don't
right I ask a question the answer is yes
or no why can't you say yes or no I
believe in the Islamic system would you
like Sharia law in this country I would
yes or no I would love to see you want
no no answer the question never mind
what I want what do you want I want to
see the Islamic system reestablish would
you like Sharia law in this country last
time I'm going to ask if Sharia law if
Sharia law or no if Sharia law means
upholding Family Values means looking
after the poor means no gays no feminist
are women who get above themselves
that's your caricature no oh I know what
Shia law wants why so why does so many
women become Muslim these days why is
that what you're going to tell me no no
why why do so many they want to be
oppressed women in the world become
Muslim these days you tell me well I
don't you better ask them why don't you
tell me what you think they they seem to
find it something that attracts them
Islam really yeah okay many many many
women in the west become Muslim and for
some reason they seem to like the fact
that it's do you work with women doctors
yes I do how how do they feel about your
views on this I keep a very strict
professional line between my they know
where your views are when they watch
this they're going to be surprised some
of them will know some of them will not
know some of them will know some of them
will not know okay doctor thank you for
coming in I appreciate it um you've been
enlightening with your responses you may
not realize quite how enlightening but
you might find out when you see the
reaction but I appreciate you coming in
thank you you're welcome on S next
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones is back
on X for Twitter a victory for free
speech or big mistake by Elon Musk we'll
debate
next
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about talk today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area no are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was president of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford
Union Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
hand thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV welome back Alex Jones is a
conspiracy theorist who made hundreds of
millions of dollars spreading the
outrageous lies at the Sandy Hook
shooting was a hoax The Grieving
familyes finally sued him for defamation
and they rewarded more than a billion
dollars but so far he hasn't paid them a
dime this is what happened last time I
tried to hold him to account do you feel
a sense of personal regret and remorse
that your actions on air that your
actions on it
inspired a lot of people to think these
people were actors and their kids didn't
really die do you feel genuine remorse
you let me talk for any 500,000 Iraqi
children starved to death did it on
purpose and you no I feel way less no I
legitimately question Sandy hook and I
stand by what I did said it was a fake
and a HOA you let me finish I'm not
going to come back on your show in 10
years and you'll say do you know
apologize if I sat here and slit my
throat on air it wouldn't be enough for
you one this weekend Alex Jones was
banned from all mainstream social media
platforms now Elon Musk has restored him
to X formerly Twitter extoling his
commitment he says to free speech but
where is the line on free speech and
does Alex Jones cross it with here a
debate it's a journalist Glen Greenwald
aggressive commentator namiki const and
YouTuber Mark mein also known as count
danula welcome to all of you okay Mark
you're with me so let's start with you
um what what do you feel about this I
mean I've written a column for the New
York Post saying I think it's an
outrageous decision by Elon Musk who
only a year ago himself said that
because one of his children had died in
his arms his own kids that he never
wanted to see anybody who would profit
from the death of children for personal
gain for fame or politics now he's done
a u-turn on that is he right yeah I
think he's completely right in doing it
must company so if he wants Alex Jones
back on the platform then he absolutely
can and he did put it to a poll to the
public you know voxpop Vox day and uh
people said they wanted them back in the
platform so he's brought them back on
theform it's an amate poll two million
of his followers voted we don't know how
many times each one voted etc etc it's
not a sophisticated each account can
only vote once yeah but but my point is
is there a line though on free speech at
all for you for me personally no nothing
no no I think that Alex Jones should be
able to go on Twitter if they want him
there then that's fine they can him
there and he can do you think what he
said about the Sandy Hook massacre was
justified then Justified like he has the
right to say it I don't wouldn't was
justified I mean 1.2 billion doar worth
of Damages awarded against him for one
of the most serious big civil suit
against an individual in the history of
America one of the worst defamations
actually in terms of Damages America's
ever seen damages and defamations not
protected by the First Amendment and yet
you think he was entitled to say it I
think he had a right to say it he a
right to to say that a mass shooting
that killed 20 young kids was a fake and
a hoax that the parents of The Grieving
dead were crisis actors these were
statements which he repeatedly made
which led to actual intimidation
harassment death and rape threats and
people in the street going up to these
people and confronting them these
parents you think all that is fine I
don't think it's fine I never said it's
fine I said I said he has a right to do
it does he ever yeah agree that someone
has a right you think he has a right to
do that yeah I think he has a right to
do it agreeing that someone has a right
to do so something isn't the same as
agreeing with what they say no no I
agree you actually think he has a right
to do what he did with the consequences
we now now happened yes if basically
yeah a bunch of nuts did do a lot of
awful stuff after the fact but that's
basically going down the same route of
you know remember back in the '90s they
wanted to ban video games and Dungeons
and Dragons because they thought it
caused violence and devil worship or you
can't you know engage with this type of
you know media otherwise it's going to
cause XYZ like rap music causes violence
all the other nonsense if we saying oh
this guy is not allowed to say his
conspiracy theories or whatever you want
to call them because some crazy guy out
there might do something mental then
nobody can talk about anything at all
well you can you just there are limits
to free speeches or everything else even
First Amendment America has a number of
limitations to it let me go to namaki k
Niki what is your response to Elon Musk
putting Alex Jones back on
X what I find so fascinating about Elon
Musk is he had he uses a very loose
absolutist definition of free speech for
his needs but for his company uh but
doesn't use the same standards for say
the algorithm I mean he has no problem
giving Russian Bots that boost some of
these guests on the show uh with the
Free Speech rights but does not give
people of color and women the same
rights so this is not an equal playing
field uh number one they're not the
government number two they're not
following the United States Free Speech
laws there is there are limitations as
you said incitement defamation fraud
threats child porn obscenity those are
uh the limitations to free speech and
there is a whole lot of that going on on
Twitter so if he wants to be an equal
playing field Free Speech absolutist
then clean up the Bots uh clean up the
algorithm make it completely transparent
and democratized and let people like me
and people of color and smaller accounts
have the same uh effect as say someone
who's being boosted by Russian Bots okay
let me bring in Glen greenw Glenn you
know you like me you're a big supporter
of the principle of free speech and
let's just lay that on the table I call
the show uncensored because I want it to
celebrate Free Speech but I've always
been aware there are limitations and
under the First Amendment which is one
of the greatest Protectors of free
speech anywhere in the world defamation
is not protected under the First
Amendment and this was clearly one of
the most serious defamations of a body
of people that America has ever seen so
I don't understand why just for that
reason alone why Elon Musk has performed
this uturn with Alex
Jones I think the issue peers is what
they do on the platform we have all
kinds of terrible people using social
media we have people who lied the United
States into a devastating war in Iraq
including the current president of the
United States we have people who defame
all the time like the guest I just heard
in my ear tried implying though she
wasn't courageous enough to say who she
meant that one of the people on this
panel is promoted by I'm sorry I don't
know why I'm hearing a voice in my ear
because I'm not actually done talk yet
so the standard peers that Elon Musk
enunciated when he first bought uh
Twitter is one that I supported even
though he hasn't always adhere to it
which is as long as people are using
that platform in ways that the law
allows speech to persist to be able to
be expressed then everybody should be
able to be heard what they do outside
the platform I don't think we want
social media Facebook saying oh this
person did something terrible off the
platform now we're going to to ban them
otherwise we're going to have big Tech
sensors who sit in Judgment of
everybody's
Behavior the platform right but on this
Alex Jones did use Twitter to amplify
his disgusting lies about Sandy Hook and
he will now be able to monetize all of
his conspiracy theories to his heart's
content on X without having paid a
single dime of the 1.2 billion damages
awarded against him we should be going
to the families of the San Hook victims
that he so cruy defamed that's my
problem with this is he's not just any
old Joe who got the platforms got
brought back this is a guy at the center
of the biggest defamation case in recent
times who hasn't paid any of his dues to
these
people but appear if he monetizes his
platform on X that is income that those
plaintiffs will easily be able to get
and if he uses the platform to spread
conspiracy theories or defamation that
falls outside of what fre speech
Absolut is and I think Twitter would be
justified in Banning him but what do you
do you ban people forever if they say
something defamatory like I said there
are people who have done a lot worse
than Alex Jones who are using Twitter
including bringing about wars lying to
deceive the public in elections and I
don't think that we want this standard
that says anything other than as long as
you say things that are within the first
amendment you should be entitled to use
social media once you don't you should
have a just punish he's been banned for
many years now and I think Elon Musk is
saying okay it's time to bring him back
and see how he uses the
platform you see my my criteria has
always been that if you were a world
leader uh or an elected official
actually of any kind at any level then I
think everything that you tweet should
be left on the historical record in
perpetuity right we just had a big issue
here with ministers losing their
WhatsApp messages The crucial part of
the pandemic shouldn't be allowed it
should all be public property this kind
of stuff so i' separate elected
officials from ordinary people like Alex
Jones but what Alex Jones what about
journalists what about journalists who
who who Li the the the UK and the us
into war there are plenty of those
people who still are doing those things
they're still lying people into Wars
they're still lying about wars do are
you comfortable with
having judg Glen what about Nazis I mean
you've defended Nazis in the past
because you're a free speech Absolut as
as a lawyer so why is that some people
get more power when it comes to free
speech more rights when it comes to free
speech but others don't again this is
not a Level Playing Feld she's she's
complaining because nobody has an
interest she's complaining because
nobody has an interest in watching her
show or listening to her on Twitter so
she's complaining that the algorithm
somet talking about algorithms in which
people do not have equal rights so
you're using that's not the case at all
that's not all assuming that you're
assuming that Alex Jones has the same
rights as everybody else on Twitter and
that is just not true you know what
listen it's it's a very interesting
debate I wish I could talk about it
longer we run out of time but thank you
for all of you all I would say is
personally there has to be a line with
people like Jones who commit atrocious
defamations I'm not held remotely
accountable for it and are then welcomed
back like free speech Heroes they're not
free speech Heroes he's a hate speech
monster for me but anyway on another
sens You can disagree as you have so
good to see you that's it from me
whatever you're up to keep it on sensed
good
night we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
they have made a statement condemning
Hamas we expect to see the crown revisit
Harry's anti-semitic Halloween costume
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about SP today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this Hammer
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the tor's love a scrap you can
almost see this coming round the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and Rich soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what rashy sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TB
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million pound so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold
that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking
for if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan should have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man mc
mouseman mc M man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
this is a major Summit President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film